Okay, so welcome to video number two of
the PTM video series. Before we move on,
let's go over what we learned in video
one, the framework. Now, probably the most
important thing to get your head around
once you understand all the parts of the
pro trader systematic process is what
constitutes or what is the actual
definition of a trade idea.
So a trade idea, not an investment idea.
So as traders, we have what we call a
trade idea generation process. And this is
made up of four parts. We need all four of
these parts for something to become an
actual trade idea. So this is
fundamentals, timing, catalysts, and trade
structure. We need all
all four for it to become a trade idea.
That is what a trade idea is defined as.
If we have one or two of them, it's not a
trade idea. Okay, we need all four of them
for it to become a trade idea. And we need
to be operating in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon. So it doesn't become an
investment idea. Okay, we have a limit, a
time limit on our trade ideas.
Now, we move from the idea stage to the
next stage, when an idea actually becomes
a live position. And when a idea becomes a
live position, what happens? Well, it's
sitting in your trading account, it's a
live position, there's capital committed,
and therefore, it becomes subject to risk
management practices. Okay. Now, once a
position is live, of course,
of course, it's already adhered to what we
call preventative risk management
measures. These are measures that we put
in place on ourselves on our portfolio, to
ensure some basic level of risk management
occurs, before we even take a position,
and the position has to adhere to that. So
when it becomes live, it's already adhered
to our preventative risk management
practices that we've put in our
in place. And what's going to happen in
place. And what's going to happen? And
what's going to happen? Well, the stock is
going to move, and it's either going to
become a winner, or a loser, we're either
going to make money, or lose money, we
have to react to the situations, we have
to react to the move in the stock. And
this is called reactive risk management.
reactive risk management. So what happens
next? Well, we take positions off. So we
go from idea stage to live position, and
then positions get taken off. And the
position will either have made money, or
lost money. And then it becomes subject to
our trader metrics,
it becomes a statistic. So it becomes part
of our track record. So the PTM video
series is going to focus on the entire
trade idea generation process. And we're
also going to be looking at preventative
risk management, and trader metrics.
What's not included in the PTM video
series is trade structures utilizing
options. This is taught in the
professional options trading masterclass.
And also what's not included is reactive
risk management, which can only be taught
live with live positions. And in ITPM
infrastructure, that is taught on a live
mentoring program with one of our mentors.
Now in video one, the framework, we also
outlined the four ITPM principles, that
being self sustainability, work ethic,
free information, and working smart, not
hard. We are going to be referring to all
of these principles throughout the video
series. So always keep them in your mind.
So now we have the framework established.
We can begin by what all pros do
immediately. Okay. Most of the time
without even thinking about it. Okay. So
pros, this comes naturally to us. We just
don't even think about this process. It's
something we do straight away. And most of
the time, we don't even think about it.
Video two, we're going to be establishing
what we're going to do.
We're going to be establishing what type
of market we are operating in. Are we
currently operating in a bull market or a
bear market? How do we actually go and get
perspective? This is our first step as pro
traders, and pro traders really just don't
even think about this step too much.
But in the learning process, but in the
learning process, it's very important for
retail traders to always remember to take
this step. In the first move, the first
situation, you always have to define what
market you're in. So in the learning
process, what you have to do is learn the
actual definition of bull markets and bear
markets.
We cannot get a proper perspective unless
we know the type of market that we're
actually in and also how it's actually
defined. And the way pro traders define
bull and bear markets is totally different
to what is popularized in the media. So
let's get straight into it, guys. Video
number two. And I'll see you at the end of
this video.
Okay, everybody, welcome back to the
computer screen. And video number two of
the professional trading masterclass video
series, getting perspective, the field of
play. Let's get stuck in. Now, this video
is going to be relatively shorter than
most videos in the video series.
We've got to get perspective. We're going
to get perspective. We're going to be
looking at bull and bear markets and the
actual definitions. So in video one, we
outline the framework that we're going to
work with in the PTM video series. Now,
much of that will be absolutely new to
most people.
watching the PTM video series. But don't
worry, as we take you through each stage
of this learning process, we're going to
keep building up your knowledge slowly,
and things always start to click into
place. So stick at it.
Additional to the framework that we showed
you in video number one, as traders, we
select our positions and trade our
portfolio outcomes.
In doing so, we have to define the
environment that we're operating in at any
one moment in time.
And as traders, our approach, even within
the framework that we operate in.
So we have to seek to get perspective on a
continual basis.
Now, this is all very, very
straightforward stuff because this is
definitions.
But this is something that you should
always be doing as a trader, defining the
environment that you're in,
even within the framework that you're
operating in, okay?
If we have no idea what type of market
that we're operating in at any one moment
in time,
then we basically have no idea where we
could be going because we don't have any
perspective.
So if you have no perspective on where
we've been, so historical perspective,
where we are now in the present,
so current perspective, and where we could
be going in the future, so expected
outcome,
then we're basically rudderless and we're
clueless as traders.
So it's very important to understand these
definitions of bull and bear markets and
what they actually mean.
Now, if you've been through the IPLT video
series, you will know that we did a lot of
statistical work
at various time horizons across multiple
asset classes.
And we essentially looked within equities
at day trading and we came to the
conclusion that it's extremely random,
okay?
And the odds of making or losing money
within a one-day timeframe in mega cap,
large cap equities,
like the S&P 500, is essentially 50-50.
It's random, okay?
So the big question is here, how do we
stack the odds in our favor, okay?
Well, if we want to stack the odds in our
favor better than that, better than the
50-50 and randomness,
like day trading, we have to have an
understanding of the bigger picture and
have perspective.
So there's four questions that every
trader should be continually asking
themselves.
Firstly, where has the market come from?
Secondly, where is the market today?
Third, where is the market going?
And four, the big one, what does it all
mean?
What does it all mean essentially implies
the main question here of what is our
perspective, okay?
Now, the only way to get perspective, the
only true way to get perspective
is to look to historical stock market
performance,
to get the perspective on the present and
to plan for the future.
So this is what we're going to do.
We're going to start looking at the
definition of bull and bear markets.
So at any one point in time in your
careers,
you can actually define what the
environment is that you are currently in
to understand where we could be going.
And, of course, for true perspective, what
it all actually means.
So these definitions essentially help us
as traders in making sense of it all.
We're trying to make sense of everything
all the time so we can make clear and
strong decisions
and correct decisions, okay?
So it stands to reason, okay, we need to
keep things simple.
So by keeping things simple, what does
that really mean in terms of our portfolio
biases, okay?
Well, when we have prolonged periods of
strong stock market performance, we
obviously do not want to be short the
market.
Our trading bias should, in this instance,
always tend towards being long.
When we have prolonged periods of weak
stock market performance, we do not want
to be long the market.
Our trading bias should very obviously
always tend towards being short in this
environment.
And, of course, if we have those two
situations, what if we have a period of
time where the stock market is essentially
flat?
It's not going up, it's not going up a
lot, it's not going down a lot, it's
trending sideways, okay?
When we have prolonged periods of flat
stock market performance, we do not want
to be very long or very short the market.
Our trading bias should be long short, or
market neutral, okay?
Now, bear markets and bull markets, they
have definitions, okay?
A bear market is defined by a 20% fall in
an index from its high.
So, an equity index like the S&P 500, the
NASDAQ, the Dow, if they fall by 20% from
their highest point, okay, that is the
definition of a bear market, okay?
A bull market, this is where some
confusion comes in.
The actual definition, the professional
trading definition of a bull market, is a
bull market is defined by a rise in the
index above the previous bear market
level.
So, there is a definition of bull markets
that's bandied about in the media a lot,
okay, which is a 20% rise in the index
from its low.
That's one definition, but it's not the
actual definition that professional
traders use.
Obviously, that's a good sign that markets
are running 20% off their lows, okay?
But have they officially, in the
professional trading and investing
community, entered a bull market?
Is the actual definition true to the money
in the market that matters?
It's not, okay?
So, on the professional side, bull markets
are defined by a rise in the index level
back above the bear market level.
So, let's have a look at some examples
from stock market history.
Let's go way back to the great financial
crisis.
So, the 2008-2009 financial crisis.
Let's start having a look at some levels
in the index of the S&P 500.
And here, we're looking at the SPX.
So, the S&P 500 cash index, okay?
Let's have a look at levels.
So, back before the financial crisis, the
SPX, S&P 500, reached a high on the 11th
of October 2007 of 1576, spot 09.
So, the bear market level, when we work
that out, we multiply the number by 0.8,
so 20% off the high.
And the bear market level was 1260, spot
87.
And that level was reached on July 7th,
2008, with a close of 1252, spot 31.
So, it closed below the bear market level
of 1260, spot 87, which is 20% off the
highs of 1576, spot 09.
So, we're using closing levels here, okay?
Now, we're not going to go into the
details here of, you know, why things
occurred and why things happened or what
could have been done about it.
We're simply looking at a moment in
history here where there was a bear market
followed by a bull market, as an example.
And we're just looking at the high, the
bear market level, the low, and the bull
market level, okay?
So, this can be used as a template,
essentially, at any moment in time to look
at current levels and assess where bear
market levels exist and potentially where
bull market levels exist if we are in a
bear market.
So, we're not going to go into the reasons
why things happened.
We're just objectively looking at this and
looking at the levels and understanding
that it's a template that we can use to
get perspective on any moment.
So, if you can get perspective on history,
you get perspective in the present, you
can understand the parameters of the
markets that you're in, the environments
that you're in, for the potential of the
future.
And we can zoom in here and just have a
look in a bit more detail during the
global financial crisis of 2008-09 and
understand the levels a little bit better
and understand the trading activity around
that time.
So, if we look in July 2008, when the bear
market level was breached, so the 0.8
multiplied by the high level, so 12.60
spot 8.7, we can see that when we entered
the bear market, the market then had a
rally and spent a good six weeks, roughly,
trading above the bear market level.
Before it collapsed again, okay, through
the bear market level.
So, you can understand here that, you
know, at the time, imagine yourself as a
trader and you've identified the bear
market level.
You understand the parameter and you
understand the environment you're in.
It breaks the bear market level for the
first time.
Obviously, that's not a good sign.
So, even though there was a period where
it traded around that level and above, you
would probably be thinking to yourself, as
a trader, this is not good.
And you had quite a long time to sort
yourself out, where you could sort out
your portfolios and get your risk in a
position that was acceptable for the
environment that you were in at the time.
And this is why it's so important to
understand these parameters and
definitions in order to understand the
environment you're in.
Because, as a trader, you can objectively
understand what is happening in the market
from both a historical perspective, in a
current perspective, and a perspective of
what to expect in the future.
And in this example here, where we entered
bear market territory for the first time,
you would be sitting there as a trader,
obviously thinking this is not good.
And you can get your risk into an
acceptable position where you can ensure
that you're not long, you're not net long
or have a long bias.
Yes.
Now, we can also look at the bull market
level when we came out of the financial
crisis.
So, if we look a little bit further on in
time, we can see that the low of the S&P
500 was reached on the 6th of March 2009
at 666.79.
Now, we know the bear market level
previously was 1260, spot 87, which was
first breached on the 7th of July 2008.
Okay, now, the bear market level becomes
the new bull market level, okay, that's
the professional trader definition.
And that was breached from below for the
first time with a close of 1271, spot 87
on the 3rd of January 2011.
And we would define that as the first day
that the S&P 500 officially entered a bull
market.
Now, it's interesting from a historical
perspective, because when you think of the
global financial crisis, you would think
intuitively from memory that the S&P 500
came out of a bear market much quicker
than it did.
Officially, it came out in January 2011,
came out of the bull market.
But thinking back now to that moment in
time, we think, a lot of people think that
the market came out of a bear market much
quicker.
It didn't.
It took quite a long time, okay?
The reason that people think that is
because of the definition that's bandied
about in the media of a market coming out
of a bear market and entering a bull
market being defined as a rally of 20% off
the lows.
That's just incorrect.
That's something that the media pushes
around, and it's not the professional
trader definition.
The professional trading and investment
community seek an index to go back above
the bear market level as a genuine
definition and a signal that we have
officially entered a bull market.
Now, interestingly enough, similar to
where the market breached the bear market
level on the way down and was hanging
around that level for a number of weeks,
if not a few months.
When the S&P 500 rallied above the bear
market level to enter officially into a
bull market back then, you can see on the
chart that the market was hanging around
for a number of months at or below or
slightly above the new bull market level.
So imagine you're a trader sitting at that
time, you would have taken the signal on
that day where the market officially
entered the bull market, you would have
taken that signal and you would have taken
it as a sign, as a bullish sign.
And you probably would have been asking
yourself some very serious questions about
being short that market.
Okay.
Why?
Because, you know, from historical
perspective, okay, that the parameters
that we're dealing with for entering bear
markets, entering bull markets are very
well defined and they are very strong
signals.
So, you probably wouldn't have been short,
you would have been leaning towards being
long in your portfolio, having a long
bias.
Now, what about a more recent historical
example?
Let's have a look at the COVID sell-off in
2020.
The S&P 500, the high, was reached on the
19th of February 2020, and the level of
the high was 3,393 spot 52.
Again, we use the same formula, we just
multiply the high by 0.8 to get the bear
market level, which is 2,714 spot 82.
On the way down, that was reached on the
12th of March 2020, with a close of 2,480
spot 64.
Now, you can see when we compare this
situation to the situation in the global
financial crisis, you can see that this
happened at a much faster pace.
Okay.
The sell-off was quicker.
But, look at the levels, and then look at
the low of around 2,200.
Okay.
You can see that from the bear market
level, which was 2,714 spot 82, down to
the low, which is 2,200.
That's still a very big move.
Okay.
So, imagine a lot of the constituents in
the S&P 500.
And I can tell you from experience, a lot
of them still went down 40, 50, 60, 70%
from this level.
Okay.
Because the move was actually very, very
big from the bear market level, and very,
very quick.
Now, objectively, again, using this
template, on that day, when the S&P 500
breached the bear market level, it
breached from above the bear market level,
you would have been asking yourself some
very, very serious questions about being
long.
Okay.
And you can see the day after the market
actually went up.
It was extremely volatile.
But objectively, you probably would not
have been long at this point, if you
respected the bear market level
definition.
Okay.
Coming out of the bear market, we look at
the same level, the bear market level.
So, the 2714 spot 82, and we look at the
day that it actually went above that.
It closes above that.
Okay.
When does that happen?
Well, it happens for the first time with a
close of 2,749.98 on the 8th of April,
2020.
So, that's when we officially entered a
bull market.
And again, similar to when it happens on
the way down, I'm breaching the bear
market level from above.
When it's breaching the bull market level
from below, that's when we enter the bull
market.
And as traders, we're asking ourselves
some very, very serious questions about
being short.
We're probably leaning towards a longer
bias in our portfolio.
Okay.
Now, when you look at the chart visually,
it seems like the bear market level and
the bull market level, the bull market
level looks visually that it broke to the
upside earlier.
Well, it doesn't.
Go and check the numbers.
It's because we're using closing prices.
Okay.
And the market was extremely volatile at
that stage.
During that time, the market was just
gapping everywhere.
The actual closing level because we're
using closing prices all the time of the
official day for entering a bull market
out of the COVID crisis was on the 8th of
April, 2020.
So, where the arrow is pointing there.
So, very important to get these
definitions, guys, because, again, you can
get perspective on historical stock market
performance.
You can overlay these parameters onto any
moment in history, at any moment in time
in the present, and understand where we've
come from, and have an idea of where we
are,
and have an expectation of where we might
be going in the current context of the
market, and what it all means.
So, getting that perspective.
Okay.
Feel free to repeat the analysis over the
last few cycles for a number of indices.
Remember the self-starter mentality.
Go and get the data.
Okay.
And have a look at when the indices that
we have on the slide here entered bear
markets and entered bull markets.
It's a worthwhile exercise to do.
And what you will find is that not all
markets enter and exit bear markets at the
same time.
There can be some fairly significant lags.
It's just a very interesting exercise for
you to do as a new person in the financial
markets, or someone who's new to this
exercise.
To understand the history of financial
markets and to get perspective with the
actual definitions from the professional
trading and investing community.
I.e. the money in the market that really
matters.
In the download section for video number
two, you will have access to a
spreadsheet.
Just download it from the downloads area.
You'll see the analysis that we've done on
the indices like the Nasdaq 100 and the
Nasdaq Composite.
The Dow Jones Industrial Average.
The Eurostoxx 50 and 600 in Europe.
The FTSE 100, 250, 350 in the UK.
The DAX 30 in Germany.
In Hong Kong.
In Japan.
And in Australia.
We've given you some examples there.
You can apply this perspective to any
equity index in the world.
And you can apply it to any stock in the
world.
Okay.
So go to the download section.
Have a look at the examples there.
And repeat the process yourself.
Have a look at the data.
And have a look at the charts.
It's interesting to get perspective and
understand what's going on.
So, now that we've got a perspective on
what constitutes a bull and bear market.
We will always know what type of market we
are actually in at any given time.
Okay.
That's great.
That's a good foundation and a good
perspective to have.
It's extremely useful.
What we now have to learn is how to
predict whether we're going to go into a
bull market or a bear market.
And whether we will actually stay in a
bull or bear market.
And on top of that, how we can actually
build portfolios in order to take
advantage of all situations in the
financial markets.
But before we do that, let's go back to
the desk for a brief recap of bull and
bear markets.
And then we'll get stuck in to video
number three.
Okay.
So, welcome back to the desk.
So, you now know how to actually define
bull and bear markets in the same way that
professional traders do.
Now, this is important because if you know
how to do this at any one time in the
future, you will know the parameters of
the market that you're operating in.
But what's important is to also get
historical perspective and to understand
market history.
Now, as you've seen in the video, there is
a download that is associated with this
video.
And there's going to be many downloads
throughout the PTM video series.
Use the downloads.
Utilize them.
They are fantastic resources.
Okay.
Use them and learn throughout the video
series.
Now, what you have to learn now is not
just what type of market you're in,
whether that's a bull or a bear market,
but we have to now be able to predict
whether we are going to go into a bull or
bear market and whether we are going to
stay in a bull or bear market.
And how we can actually build portfolios
in order to take advantage of all these
situations.
So, where do we start?
We start with gross domestic product, GDP.
Let's get straight into the next video on
GDP.
And I'll see you at the end of the next
video.